welcome back IceCube I missed you
21 Jump Street stars Jonah Hill and
Channing Tatum and it's a remake of the
80s television show with Johnny Depp
these high schoolers are known for
passing this new drug around that
actually cause more of them to die so
Channing Tatum and Jonah Hill are these
two new cops and they get their first
big assignment is to go undercover at
this school because they still kind of
look maybe like they could be in high
school and they're supposed to try to
infiltrate this school get in with the
cool people and try to figure out where
this drug is going now of course the
comedy in this is that they really don't
look like they're in high school they're
like the biggest high schoolers ever and
there's so much comedy to be had with
that I was really hoping the movie was
going to be able to address that well
because that situation is just right for
comedy and it really did I thought this
movie was hysterical it's been a while
since I've seen a really good comedy and
this movie had me laughing from start to
finish
I really enjoyed 21 Jump Street my
favorite part of this movie was how
self-aware it was and how self
referential it was it made fun of itself
so often situation these cops are in the
fact that they obviously do not look
like kids they made fun of all the cop
cliches the hopping over the car the
expecting something to explode but in
reality it probably wouldn't like all
those cliches that come with cop movies
they made fun of it in this movie and
when a comedy has a lot of really
sophomoric humor in it it's really
important for it to be kind of aware of
that and kind of relish in that be able
to say yet look we know we're kind of
stupid right now but we love the fact
that we're making stupid and dumb jokes
and that's one of the reasons why for me
a lot of the jokes really work in this
movie because it was just so aware of
what it was Channing Tatum is continuing
to grow on me I have really liked his
performances in the past few movies he's
done I think he's really blossoming into
a good actor he was hilarious in this
movie like he really got a lot of big
laughs Jonah Hill was really great in
this movie too and they actually kind of
poked fun at his skinny but not really
skinny yet stature like the he let
everyone just make fun of him for it I
love that too they had excellent
chemistry with one another I thought
they work really well together both of
those characters just play off from each
other so well ice cubes in this movie
yes from anaconda I know he's no other
things too but anaconda always sticks
out in my mind I don't know why cuz it's
awesome and stupid and it's anaconda but
Ice Cube plays the guy that's in charge
of instructing them what to do with this
school and he is gold in this movie he
is so hilarious very angry he's always
just he's always on them he's busting
their balls like all the time
he
can't stand them and it gets so many
great scenes between the three of them
there's one of the better comedies I've
seen in a while non-stop laughs good
characters a situation you can get
behind good chemistry people who play
off each other really well you can tell
us lots of good improv going on the only
problems I really have the film was
towards the end it gets a little bit
more serious like we have to get into
the plot now and you lose a little bit
of the comedy not too much though they
preserved a lot of it and there's a
situation in the end that I don't want
to spoil that it seemed like it was kind
of unnecessary to go in the direction
they did for it I can't really spoil it
but if you saw the movie you know that
there's someone there and it seems like
they just didn't really handle the way I
would have liked it but these are small
gripes I really enjoyed 21 Jump Street
I'm gonna give it a B+ it's one of the
better comedies I've seen in a while
I'd like to know do you guys have a
favorite cop film of any kind I'm
thinking mine might be Lethal Weapon or
if you count diehard maybe but Lethal
Weapon is more of a cop film than die
hard is so I might go with that one
until next time guys if you liked this
review you can subscribe to my channel
and get steppen eyes
Oh